How exciting, or daunting, or whatever it is to know that you're stepping into these very famous red boots?
Yeah, extremely exciting.
I mean, the opportunity of a lifetime.
Everyone has, at some point, pretended to be Superman as a boy...
...and I get the opportunity to play this enormous icon.
So, I'm ecstatic, obviously.
I'm very excited and I really can't wait to get my teeth sunk into the whole thing.
And, you know, get things going.
I first learned your name when the Bond stuff was going on.
Now, Craig only has like, I think he said, only one or two more films.
As you said, you're only 27, would you still be interested?
Of course, James Bond? Yeah.
Yeah, that's the other one to get.
You get Superman, you get James Bond.